kirsten gillibrand is in that race and
is not just a candidate but really a
living metaphor jill grant is someone
who's lived a remarkably fortunate life
until about ten years ago she was a
member of congress virtually nobody
outside the mostly rural xx
congressional district in upstate New
York had ever heard of her she was
considered a thoroughly average member
of Congress maybe a little below average
and then one day Hillary Clinton decided
to run for president and Gillibrand hit
paydirt
she was plucked from obscurity and
handed one of the safest Senate seats in
America overnight Gillibrand became a
national figure without even having to
win an election amazing it was the
political equivalent of inheriting a
billion dollars maybe not surprisingly
Gillibrand views changed accordingly she
soon adopted the politics of the trust
fund left before long there wasn't a
fashionable opinion she didn't have on
any topic guns abortion immigration you
name it as her friends in Aspen and
Martha's Vineyard became more decadent
and more contemptuous of the country
around them
so did Kirsten Gillibrand by this past
weekend when she appeared on Face the
Nation
Gillibrand was arguing against
continuing to operate the United States
as a sovereign country let everyone in
she demanded detaining anyone is immoral
watch but you oppose even what the Obama
administration did in terms of keeping
families together or keeping them
together for a longer period of time in
detention
I wouldn't as president the United
States I wouldn't use the detention
system at all Homeland Security those
saying hundreds of thousands of people
are crossing the border and they need to
go somewhere before their Asylum claims
are actually heard what would you do
with them they don't need to be
incarcerated they can if they're given a
lawyer and given a process they will
follow it hundreds of thousands of
people millions of people over time
where will all those people go well they
won't go to kirsten gillibrand
neighborhood obviously they're not
headed to Martha's Vineyard or Aspen or
Southampton obviously but they're going
to dying industrial cities that
Gillibrand believes could use more
Democratic voters what the state of New
York does well is we te to actually take
refugee families into our communities we
would be delighted to take refugee
families
to cities like Buffalo and Syracuse and
Rochester and Albany so think for a
minute about what Gillibrand is saying
here she's arguing that anybody from
anywhere in the world must be allowed
into the United States awarded a
publicly financed lawyer given a free
place to live along with free health
care and schools all what you pay for
and allowed to stay indefinitely unless
they lose a court case that by the way
they will definitely show up for that's
her core assumption the people who have
demonstrated contempt for our laws will
arrive in court when asked Gillibrand
trust them to do that and why wouldn't
she trust them that's the base that's
the whole immigration argument that
she's making which is that unlike you
regular Americans who are lazy and
stupid and not worth helping immigrants
are basically perfect they're smarter
more industrious more creative than you
or any of your american-born neighbors
were or could be that's what they
believe the facts suggest a more
complicated picture recently ice
launched a pilot program to conduct DNA
tests of adults and children arriving at
El Paso and McAllen Texas the border
crossings there when they checked they
found that nearly 1/3 of the kids were
not related to the adults they were with
it was fraud on a massive scale it also
reveals something far darker it reveals
that our deliberate failure to protect
our borders has made our own government
party to the trafficking of children it
would be hard overall to design an
immigration system that's worse for a
country our country but Democrats don't
care to a party totally controlled by
identity politics everything is about
race or gender or sexuality
nothing else matters including reality
watch congresswoman Maxine Waters
explain that giving preference to
immigrants who speak English is can you
guess racist some of that is very racist
it is not keeping with what this country
is supposed to be all about what exactly
just so our viewers know are you saying
is racist there well you know this
business about you must speak English
we're going to give you points for
speaking English and we don't want our
poor people
we only want those people who are
earning substantial wages already I
think there's some of those policies or
races
imagine the CNN anchor asking of Maxine
Waters just to be specific what is
racist everything of course but in this
specific case she and virtually everyone
else in her party is arguing that
Americans have no right to want
immigrants who speak English Americans
have no right to one immigrants with job
skills Nancy Pelosi explained that last
week Americans have no right to decide
how many immigrants come here or how
long they stay and yet as camel Harris
and Joe Biden and others have just told
us Americans are required to pay for
free health care for everyone who comes
along with housing and education and
lots of others got that you can see
where all this is heading and fast in
France they're nearly there this was the
scene at Charles de Gaulle the country's
biggest airport yesterday hundreds of
illegal immigrants from Africa took over
a terminal to make political demands
at one point a leader of that
demonstration chanted this into a
loudspeaker quote France does not belong
to the French everyone has a right to be
here
kirsten gillibrand would agree with that
America for Americans
that's racist you don't deserve your own
country to Gillibrand a-- and her
friends on the left America is not a
nation it's a pinata filled with 200
years of treasure get some quick before
it's gone
that's what Gillibrand is promising the
world how long will four groups of angry
illegal aliens protest in this country
where's our share of the Spoils they'll
wonder the one that Gillibrand told us
about that day is coming soon